Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at PathwaysAlliance.ca
加拿大油砂产业产生了大量碳排放，因此六家最大的公司携手合作，在迈向净零排放的道路上取得进展。投资于技术与 innovation。每桶排放量平均已减少22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位。开发世界最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请在PathwaysAlliance.ca查看我们的行动计划。
For newlyweds Gail and Rick Brink, finding a dream home where they could settle down and start a family was at the top of their agenda. The couple met at work in 1984 when Gail was 19 years old and Rick was 25. With her long, wavy dark hair and athletic figure, Gail immediately caught Rick's attention. He knew right away that Gail was the one and told his mother later that day, I just met the woman I'm going to marry. Before long the pair were an item and were planning their wedding. On April 25, 1986, the day after Gail's 21st birthday, they were married in a simple church service in front of their closest friends and family.
对于新婚夫妇盖尔（Gail）和里克·布林克（Rick Brink）来说，寻找一个可以安家落户并组建家庭的梦想之家是他们首要任务。这对夫妇于1984年在工作中相识，当时盖尔19岁，里克25岁。盖尔留着长长的深色波浪卷发，身材健美，立刻引起了里克的注意。他一眼就看出盖尔就是他苦苦寻觅的另一半，并在那天晚些时候对母亲说，我刚遇到了我要娶的女人。不久之后，两人便确立了恋爱关系，并开始筹备婚礼。1986年4月25日，在盖尔21岁生日的第二天，他们在亲朋好友的见证下，于一家简朴的教堂举行了婚礼。
Gail wore an elegant white dress with a flared skirt and spaghetti straps, while Rick wore a bright blue suit jacket and matching bow tie. The reception took place at a lakefront country club where guests danced all night long. After it was over, the bride and groom departed for their honeymoon, a romantic cruise where they would be able to spend lots of time on the beach soaking up sunshine. After Gail and Rick returned to their hometown of Holland, Michigan, they turned their attention to buying a house. One eventually caught their eye.
盖尔身穿优雅的白色连衣裙，裙摆外扩，带有细肩带，而里克则穿着一件亮蓝色西装外套和相配的领结。招待会在一家湖畔乡村俱乐部举行，宾客们通宵达旦地跳舞。仪式结束后，新郎新娘出发去度蜜月，那是一次浪漫的游轮之旅，他们将有大量时间在海滩上沐浴阳光。盖尔和里克回到家乡密歇根州荷兰镇后，便把注意力转向了买房。最终，有一处房子吸引了他们的目光。
Located on the outskirts of town, it was a small weatherboard ranch house that sat on 20 acres of land. There was no doubt the property had seen better days. Inside, cabinets were falling off their hinges, paint was peeling, and the rooms were in desperate need of an upgrade. But it had great potential and Rick was confident he could turn it into their dream home. His job involved training carpenters at a furniture company and he was a talented handyman. With some help from his father, Rick negotiated a deal and was able to buy the house and land for a steal.
这栋房子位于镇郊，是一座小型木板平房，占地20英亩。毫无疑问，这处房产已经风光不再。走进屋内，橱柜脱落，墙漆剥落，各个房间急需翻新。但它具有巨大的潜力，里克有信心把它变成他们梦想中的家。他的工作涉及在一家家具公司培训木匠，而且他是个很有天赋的杂工。在父亲的帮助下，里克谈妥了一笔交易，以极低的价格买下了这栋房子和土地。
After moving into the property in October 1987, the newlyweds set about transforming it. They went through the house room by room, scrubbing them from floor to ceiling, making repairs and repainting the walls. Rick documented their progress with the camcorder. He chatted about the house as he filmed each room and checked in on Gail, who paused her work to smile and wave at him. By November, the couple had been married for a year and a half and were ready to start renovating one room of their house in particular,
1987年10月搬进新居后，这对新婚夫妇便着手改造这所房子。他们逐个房间进行清洁，从地板到天花板进行擦洗，维修并重新粉刷了墙壁。里克用摄像机记录了他们的进展。他在拍摄每个房间时谈论着房子，并查看盖尔的情况，盖尔停下手里的活，向他微笑挥手。到了11月，这对夫妇已经结婚一年半了，准备开始装修他们房子的其中一个房间，
a nursery, in preparation for the baby they hoped to have soon. Everything seemed to be going perfectly. Gail Brink had an office job at an auto parts company where she was well regarded as a diligent and hard working employee. So, when she didn't show up for work on the morning of Monday, November 23, her absence was immediately noticed. There was no sign of Rick at his workplace either. Knowing how responsible Rick was, his employer decided to check in with his family.
即育儿室，为他们希望不久后出生的宝宝做准备。一切似乎都在完美地进行。盖尔·布林克在一家汽车零部件公司做办公室文员，被认为是一个勤奋好学的员工。因此，当她在11月23日星期一早上没有去上班时，她的缺席立刻引起了注意。里克的公司也没有他的踪迹。深知里克是个多么有责任感的人，他的雇主决定向他的家人了解情况。
Garrett and Ida Brink were surprised to receive a call informing them that their son hadn't been seen that day. Rick and Gail had attended a friend's wedding over the weekend, but they'd had no plans that would have kept them from work. Garrett and Ida decided to drive over to their house to check that everything was alright. When they arrived at the sprawling property north of Holland, Garrett and Ida noticed something. Rick's SUV, a Chevrolet Blazer, was parked in the driveway.
加勒特（Garrett）和艾达·布林克（Ida Brink）接到电话，得知他们的儿子那天没有去上班，感到很惊讶。里克和盖尔刚在周末参加了一个朋友的婚礼，但他们并没有什么会耽误工作的计划。加勒特和艾达决定开车去他们家看看一切是否安好。当他们到达荷兰镇北部的这处广阔房产时，加勒特和艾达注意到了一件事。里克的SUV雪佛兰开拓者停在车道上。
That meant he must be at home. They went over to inspect the vehicle and saw something shocking. Rick was inside, slumped across the driver's seat with his head pressed against the passenger door. Blood was visible from at least one head wound. He was dead. When officers from the Ottawa County Sheriff's Department arrived, they secured the scene before walking into the home. Upon entering, they headed down the long hallway that led to the master bedroom.
这意味着他一定在家。他们走过去检查这辆车，看到了令人震惊的一幕。里克坐在车里，瘫倒在驾驶座上，头紧贴着乘客车门。至少有一处头部伤口清晰可见血迹。他已经死了。渥太华县治安官办公室的警员赶到后，在走进屋里之前封锁了现场。进入屋内后，他们顺着通往主卧室的长长走廊往前走。
The room was tidy aside from some clothing that was strewn across the floor. Lying in the couple's water bed was 22-year-old Gail Brink. She looked as though she could be asleep, except for one thing. A blood-stained pillow had been placed over her head. When police lifted it, Gail's lifeless and bloody face was exposed. She had been shot in the head three times. Initially, officers wondered if they were dealing with a murder suicide. Perhaps Rick had killed his wife while she lay sleeping, then gone out into his Chevy Blazer to take his own life.
房间很整洁，除了地上散落的一些衣服。22岁的盖尔·布林克正躺在夫妻俩的水床上。她看起来就像是睡着了，除了有一点不同。一个沾满血迹的枕头盖在她的头上。警察掀开枕头，盖尔毫无生气且血迹斑斑的脸露了出来。她的头部被枪击了三次。起初，警员们怀疑这是一起谋杀后自杀案。也许里克在妻子熟睡时杀死了她，然后走到他的雪佛兰开拓者车里结束了自己的生命。
But when investigators moved Rick's body, there was no gun lying beneath him. Nor was there one anywhere else in the car. Rick couldn't have been the killer. Like Gail, he'd been shot by someone else, execution style, with two bullet wounds in his head. Judging from the position of his body, he'd been sitting in the driver's seat when he was shot from the left side. Then he fell to the right, his head coming to rest on the passenger seat. The driver's side window was wound slightly down. A bullet hole through the passenger window had shattered the glass.
但是当调查人员移动里克的遗体时，他身下并没有枪。车里其他地方也没有枪。里克不可能是凶手。和盖尔一样，他是被其他人以行刑式枪决，头部有两处枪伤。从他尸体的位置来看，他坐在驾驶座上时从左侧遭到枪击。然后他向右倒下，头靠在乘客座上。驾驶座车窗稍微降下。乘客车窗上的一个弹孔击碎了玻璃。
The killer had likely stood by the driver's door and aimed at the gun through the open window. Aside from the two victims and the few items of clothing lying on their bedroom floor, nothing in the house was out of place. There was no sign of forced entry. All of the furniture was upright and drawers were closed. Cash was found throughout the home. Gail's purse had been left on the kitchen counter, as had Rick's wallet. Both had all their contents, including credit cards and the driver's licenses. Gail and Rick were still wearing their wedding rings and other jewellery, and two watches were also found in the home.
凶手可能站在驾驶座车门旁，透过打开的车窗将枪对准了他。除了两名受害者和卧室地板上的几件衣服外，房子里的其他东西都井然有序。没有强行闯入的迹象。所有的家具都是直立的，抽屉都是关着的。房子里到处都能找到现金。盖尔的钱包被落在厨房柜台上，里克的钱包也是。两者的所有内容都完好无损，包括信用卡和驾照。盖尔和里克仍然戴着结婚戒指和其他首饰，屋里还找到了两块手表。
Clearly, robbery hadn't been the killer's motive. The entire crime scene was unsettlingly clean, and there was little physical evidence to go on. Gail and Rick had both been shot with a 22 gauge revolver, but there was no sign of the murder weapon anywhere in the house. Nor were there any bullet casings. Detectives didn't recover any suspicious clothing or any strands of hair. Only six usable prints were recovered from the crime scene. Four fingerprints belonged to the two victims. Another print was found on a toilet, and there was also one on the telephone.
很明显，抢劫并不是凶手的动机。整个犯罪现场干净得令人不安，几乎没有什么物证可依。盖尔和里克都是被一把22口径左轮手枪射杀的，但屋里没有任何凶器的痕迹。也没有任何弹壳。侦探们没有找到任何可疑的衣服或任何头发。犯罪现场只提取到了六枚可用的指纹。四枚指纹属于两名受害者。另一个指纹在马桶上发现，还有一个在电话上。
But these didn't match anyone in the police database. Faced with this dearth of physical evidence, detectives knew they would need to dig into the victim's lives. The last time anyone had seen Gail and Rick alive was on the night of Saturday, November 21, when they attended the wedding of one of Rick's high school friends. It seemed as though they had a good night. Rick had a few drinks, and Gail became rather tipsy before they left at around 11pm. The following day, Gail's brother, Ryan Winegarden, tried to call her at home, but there was no answer. Ryan had thought nothing of this at the time, but investigators speculated that the couple had been killed in the early hours of Sunday morning, after arriving home from the wedding.
但这些指纹与警方数据库中的任何人都不匹配。面对如此匮乏的物证，侦探们知道他们需要深入调查受害者的生活。任何人最后一次看到盖尔和里克活著是在11月21日星期六的晚上，当时他们参加了里克的一位高中朋友的婚礼。他们似乎度过了一个美好的夜晚。里克喝了几杯，盖尔在晚上11点左右离开前也有点微醉。第二天，盖尔的弟弟瑞安·温加顿（Ryan Winegarden）试图打电话给她，但无人接听。瑞安当时并没有多想，但调查人员推测这对夫妇是在星期天清晨从婚礼回家后被杀害的。
The couple's family and friends were left in shock over the brutal slaying, with Ryan Winegarden telling local newspaper The Holland Sentinel, They were the nicest people in the world. I've never seen a couple get along better than they did. Gail had been one of eight children. Her family was close, but they struggled financially, which led to Gail dreaming of the day when she could finally be self-sufficient. She used to tell her big sister, Cheryl, how she planned to work as hard as she needed to, so she would always have enough money to buy herself whatever she wanted. Her first job was waitressing at a restaurant, where she earned excellent money despite the low wages. Gail was so funny, friendly and charming, that her customers always tipped generously.
这对夫妇的家人和朋友对这场残酷的谋杀案感到震惊，瑞安·温加顿对当地报纸《荷兰哨兵报》说：“他们是世界上最好的人。我从未见过比他们感情更好的情侣。”盖尔是八个孩子中的一个。她的家庭很亲密，但经济困难，这导致盖尔梦想着有一天能真正自立。她经常告诉姐姐谢丽尔（Cheryl），她计划尽其所能努力工作，以便永远有足够的钱给自己买任何想要的东西。她的第一份工作是在一家餐馆当服务员，尽管工资不高，但她赚了很多小费。盖尔是如此风趣、友好和迷人，以至于她的顾客总是慷慨地给小费。
And when she met Rick, it seemed as though everything was falling into place. Not only were the young couple head over heels in love, but they were compatible too. Both were ambitious and didn't mind hard work. Their dream was a simple one, they wanted to raise a family and create a home where they could live for the rest of their lives. Rick swept Gail off her feet, spoiling her and giving her whatever she wanted. The young couple loved to travel, and during the summer months they would visit Rick's parents' house on the shores of Lake Michigan. Rick kept a boat out there and introduced Gail to water skiing. His friend Bill Whedon later told the television program a wedding and a murder that Gail was like liquid sunshine to Rick.
当她遇到里克时，一切似乎都水到渠成。这对年轻夫妇不仅深陷爱河，而且十分契合。两人都雄心勃勃，并不介意辛苦工作。他们的梦想很简单，就是抚养一个家庭，创造一个可以度过余生的家。里克对盖尔一见倾心，对她百般溺爱，要什么给什么。这对年轻夫妇喜欢旅行，夏天的时候他们会去里克父母位于密歇根湖畔的房子。里克在那里存了一艘船，并教会了盖尔滑水。他的朋友比尔·惠顿（Bill Whedon）后来告诉电视节目《婚礼与谋杀案》，对里克来说，盖尔就像流动的阳光。
She was the kind of person who could light up a room just by entering it. But despite the idyllic life the pair had together, the beginning of their relationship hadn't exactly been smooth sailing. Prior to meeting Rick, Gail had another serious boyfriend named Lars. She'd moved in with him when she was 18 years old and they'd built a house together. They'd been living together for about a year when Gail met Rick at work. She quickly ended her relationship so she could be with Rick, but Lars didn't take the news well. As she was packing her belongings to move out, he slammed a drawer closed on her hand. He also hit Gail, giving her a black eye.
她是那种只要走进房间就能点亮整个房间的人。然而，尽管两人有着田园诗般的生活，但他们的恋爱关系的开始并非一帆风顺。在遇到里克之前，盖尔还有另一个认真的男朋友，名叫拉尔斯（Lars）。她18岁时就搬去跟他一起住，两人还一起建了一栋房子。他们同居大约一年后，盖尔在工作中遇到了里克。她迅速结束了这段感情以便和里克在一起，但拉尔斯对这个消息反应激烈。当她打包行李准备搬走时，他把抽屉猛地关在她的手上。他还打了盖尔，把她的眼睛打青了。
After hearing about the assault, Gail's protective big brother Ryan came to her rescue. He punched Lars, breaking his nose, then warned him, Don't you touch my sister again. When police started looking for a suspect, Ryan suggested they speak with Gail's ex-boyfriend. He believed Lars was still in love with Gail and was furious that she'd married someone else. Investigators quickly tracked Lars down. He admitted to assaulting Gail, but strongly denied having anything to do with the double homicide. When detectives asked if he would be willing to sit a polygraph test, Lars agreed.
听说袭击事件后，盖尔富有保护欲的大哥瑞安赶来解救她。他打了拉尔斯，打断了他的鼻子，然后警告他：“你再敢碰我妹妹一下试试。”当警方开始寻找嫌疑人时，瑞安建议他们找盖尔的前男友谈谈。他相信拉尔斯仍然爱着盖尔，并且对她嫁给别人感到愤怒。调查人员很快找到了拉尔斯。他承认袭击了盖尔，但坚决否认与这起双重谋杀案有任何关系。当侦探询问他是否愿意接受测谎仪测试时，拉尔斯同意了。
He passed the test. He also provided an alibi for the time of the murders. It checked out and Lars was dismissed as a suspect. Investigators went back to the drawing board. Gail and Rick Brink were farewell in a joint funeral and laid to rest in a shared plot. The detectives working the case spoke extensively with the couple's friends and family, but nobody raised any red flags. They even tracked down every person who'd been a guest at the wedding the couple attended on their last night alive. They couldn't find anyone who held a grudge against the young newlyweds.
他通过了测试。他还为谋杀发生的时间提供了不在场证明。经过核实，拉尔斯被排除嫌疑。调查人员重新回到起点。盖尔和里克·布林克在一次联合葬礼上告别，并安葬在同一个墓地里。负责此案的侦探与这对夫妇的朋友和家人进行了广泛的交谈，但没有人提出任何可疑之处。他们甚至找到了这对夫妇生命中最后一晚参加婚礼的所有宾客。他们找不到任何人对这对年轻夫妇怀恨在心。
They had no criminal histories or connections whatsoever. By all accounts, they were well-liked, upstanding citizens who'd had no bad blood with anybody. In fact, there was only one thing in their lives that seemed it could be the source of some tension. They're newly acquired home. The ranch house sat on the eerily named Ransom Street and before the couple had bought it, had belonged to a bikey who went by the nickname Shotgun Sid. Sid was a somewhat notorious figure throughout Michigan's criminal circles. He trafficked illicit drugs from the city of Detroit to the western part of the state for a bikey gang named the Highwaymen. But Sid grew disturbed after he saw dealers selling drugs to teenagers at local high schools.
他们没有任何犯罪记录或任何联系。据所有人所说，他们是深受欢迎、奉公守法的公民，与任何人都没有宿怨。事实上，他们生活中似乎只有一件事可能是某些紧张关系的根源。他们新买的房子。这栋牧场风格的房子位于一个有着诡异名字的“ランサム街”（Ransom Street），在这对夫妇买下它之前，它属于一个绰号叫“霰弹枪西德”（Shotgun Sid）的飞车党。西德在密歇根州的犯罪圈子里是个相当臭名昭著的人物。他为一个名为“高速公路人”（Highwaymen）的飞车党从底特律市向该州西部贩运非法毒品。但西德看到毒贩向当地高中的青少年出售毒品后感到不安。
He began a double life as an informant, providing federal agents with the names of individuals who were selling to children. When word got out that Sid was working with the authorities, his life was threatened. He was shot at on multiple occasions. One time, three people turned up with a shotgun at his Ransom Street address. Sid pulled out a firearm of his own and convinced the intruders to drop their weapon. It later turned out that these individuals had been looking for a car that Sid was holding as collateral for a drug debt. In addition to enduring physical threats, Shotgun Sid was struggling financially and failed to make the repayments on his house. Eventually, the bank foreclosed on his mortgage and Sid was forced to vacate the property.
他开始了双重生活，成为一名线人，向联邦特工提供向儿童贩毒的人的名单。当西德与当局合作的消息传出后，他的生命受到了威胁。他多次遭到枪击。有一次，三个人带着一把霰弹枪出现在他的兰瑟姆街住址。西德掏出自己的枪，说服闯入者放下武器。后来证明，这些人一直在寻找西德作为毒债抵押品扣押的一辆车。除了忍受人身威胁外，“霰弹枪西德”还面临着经济困难，无力偿还房屋贷款。最终，银行没收了他的抵押贷款，西德被迫腾出这处房产。
This was the reason Gail and Rick Brink had been able to buy it for such a bargain. Investigators began to wonder if the couple hadn't been the killer's targets at all. Perhaps the person who murdered them hadn't realized that Shotgun Sid no longer lived there. Maybe it was a case of mistaken identity. Detectives looked into the Detroit bikey gangs that Sid was connected to. Despite all their digging, they couldn't find anything that tied the double homicide to a gang crime. Sid tried to help as well by placing some phone calls asking for information. He couldn't find any evidence that anyone had actually been trying to kill him.
这就是盖尔和里克·布林克能够以如此划算的价格买下它的原因。调查人员开始怀疑这对夫妇根本不是凶手攻击的目标。也许谋杀他们的人没有意识到“霰弹枪西德”已经不在那里了。这可能是一起身份错认案。侦探们调查了西德与之有联系的底特律飞车党。尽管他们四处搜寻，但找不到任何将这起双重谋杀案与帮派犯罪联系起来的证据。西德也试图通过打一些电话索取信息来提供帮助。他找不到任何人真正试图杀死他的证据。
The seemingly promising lead reached a dead end. Early on the morning of December 24, just over a month after Gail and Rick were murdered, a man named Rock Wilson was making his way home. Rock worked at Sintered Metal Products in the Michigan City of Zealand and had gone straight from a shift to his work Christmas party. Before going to the party, he'd called his wife, 30-year-old Deborah Wilson, but she was planning to stay at home. It was around 5am when Rock arrived at their residence, which sat three miles north of Holland.
这个看似很有希望的线索陷入了死胡同。12月24日清晨，也就是盖尔和里克被谋杀一个多月后，一个名叫罗克·威尔逊（Rock Wilson）的男子正在回家路上。罗克在密歇根州西兰市的烧结金属产品公司工作，下班后直接去参加了单位的圣诞派对。去派对之前，他给30岁的妻子黛博拉·威尔逊（Deborah Wilson）打了电话，但她打算呆在家里。罗克到达位于荷兰镇以北三英里的住所时，大约是凌晨5点。
The house was ablaze with lights. When Rock walked inside, he found every single light switch had been turned on. There was no sign of Deborah. As Rock made his way to the sliding door that led to their enormous backyard, he realized it was open. Rock peered outside. The large field-like space that sat behind the house had a swimming pool, a garage, a trailer, and a vegetable garden. But Rock couldn't see anyone out there. Worried about his wife, Rock called his father and asked him to come over.
房子里灯火辉煌。罗克走进去时，发现每一个电灯开关都开着。没有黛博拉的踪迹。当罗克走向通往他们巨大后院的推拉门时，他发现门是开着的。罗克向外张望。房子后面那片类似田野的开阔地上有一个游泳池、一个车库、一辆拖车和一个菜园。但罗克看不到外面有任何人。由于担心妻子，罗克打电话给父亲，请他过来。
His father agreed, and soon the two men were searching together for Deborah. Finally, Rock's father spotted her. She was lying fully clothed outside near the vegetable garden. Her throat had been slashed. Police were summoned, and it didn't take long for comparisons to be made to the Brink case. The couple's houses were approximately half a mile from each other, and could be reached on foot within five minutes if you cut across the fields between them. Like the Brink murders, there was no sign of forced entry.
他的父亲同意了，很快两个男人一起寻找黛博拉。最后，罗克的父亲发现了她。她穿着衣服躺在菜园外面。她的喉咙被割断了。警方被召集，很快就与布林克案进行了对比。这对夫妇的房子相距大约半英里，如果抄近路穿过田野，步行五分钟就能到达。和布林克谋杀案一样，没有强行闯入的迹象。
Nothing had been stolen from the property, and Deborah hadn't been sexually assaulted. The Wilson's were regarded as upstanding, hardworking citizens, just as the Brinks had been. Deborah had attended the same high school as Rick, and the couple's shared mutual acquaintances. It wasn't long before the victim's neighbors began to fear there was a serial killer amongst them. Terrified locals began petitioning the Ottawa County Sheriff's Department for a stronger police presence on their streets. Brutal murders like these weren't common for the peaceful Holland area. They no longer felt safe in their homes in the wake of two violent crimes taking place so close together in such a short space of time. Detectives considered whether the cases could be related.
财物没有被盗，黛博拉也没有遭到性侵。正如布林克夫妇一样，威尔逊夫妇也被认为是奉公守法、辛勤工作的公民。黛博拉曾和里克就读于同一所高中，两人有共同的熟人。不久之后，受害者的邻居们开始担心他们中间出了一个连环杀手。惊恐的当地人开始向渥太华县治安官办公室请愿，要求在他们的街道上加强警力。对于宁静的荷兰镇来说，这样残酷的谋杀并不常见。在短时间内发生如此接近的两起暴力犯罪之后，他们不再觉得自己在家中是安全的。侦探们开始考虑这些案件是否有关联。
In addition to these two crimes, which occurred within a month of each other, there was also an older homicide that remained unsolved. Ten years earlier in 1977, 20-year-old Deborah Polinski had been sexually assaulted and stabbed to death. She'd lived less than half a mile north of the Brink residence. Given how quiet and safe Ottawa County tended to be, having three brutal homicides take place within a stone's throw of each other seemed more than a little suspicious. However, investigators found nothing tying the Brink murders to those of Deborah Wilson or Deborah Polinski. The execution style slaying of the newlyweds convinced detectives that they'd been deliberately targeted. Yet without a motive, discovering why they'd been killed was near impossible. The case remained front-page news throughout West Michigan for months.
除了这两个在一个月内发生的犯罪之外，还有一起较早且未破的凶杀案。十年前的1977年，20岁的黛博拉·波林斯基（Deborah Polinski）遭到性侵并被刺身亡。她生前住在布林克住宅以北不到半英里的地方。鉴于渥太华县一向安静安全，发生三起相距咫尺的残酷凶杀案显得相当可疑。然而，调查人员没有发现任何证据将布林克谋杀案与黛博拉·威尔逊或黛博拉·波林斯基的谋杀案联系起来。新婚夫妇遭到行刑式枪决，这使侦探们确信他们是故意被针对的。然而，由于没有动机，发现他们被杀的原因几乎是不可能的。几个月来，该案一直是密歇根州西部各大报纸的头条新闻。
Tips came in from the public steadily, averaging around four or five a day, but none ever led anywhere. One of Gayle's colleagues reported that although she'd always been a happy-go-lucky person, her demeanor suddenly changed about two weeks before her death. She suddenly seemed reserved, as though she had a lot on her mind. Behavioural experts from the FBI and Michigan State Police were consulted, but no breakthroughs followed. Months turned into years, and eventually the case went cold. Gayle and Rick's loved ones began grappling with the upsetting notion that their case might never be solved. On November 29, 1997, a decade after Gayle and Rick were murdered, local newspaper The Marshall Chronicle published an article reminding readers about the unsolved crime. The county's under-sheriff, who'd been lead investigator on the case, described the double homicide as cold and lacking emotion.
公众源源不断地提供线索，平均每天四到五条，但没有一条取得进展。盖尔的一位同事报告说，尽管她一直是个乐天派，但在她死前两周左右，她的神情突然变了。她突然显得很内向，好像心事重重。警方咨询了联邦调查局和密歇根州警察局的行为专家，但没有取得任何突破。几个月变成了几年，最终案件陷入僵局。盖尔和里克的亲人开始痛苦地意识到，他们的案件可能永远无法破获。1997年11月29日，即盖尔和里克遇害十年后，当地报纸《马歇尔纪事报》发表了一篇文章，提醒读者注意这起未破的罪案。曾担任该案首席调查员的县副治安官将这起双重谋杀案描述为冷酷且缺乏情感。
Rick's mother, Ida, also gave an interview, stating, You're thinking all the time. Is that person around here? Does he look us in the face and know that he killed our son? It took more than another decade before there was further development in the case. In 2007, the Ottawa County Sheriff's Department launched a new cold case unit. A team of investigators who would dedicate 100% of their time to solving old crimes. Detectives Dave Blakely and Avenus Ripper would lead the unit. The two detectives first started working on the Deborah Wilson case, which also remained unsolved. They honed in on a prime suspect, but when he died before an arrest could be made, they turned their attention to the brink murders.
里克的母亲艾达也接受了采访，她说：“你一直在想。那个人就在附近吗？他会看着我们的脸，明知自己杀害了我们的儿子吗？”又过了一个多十年，案件才有了进一步的发展。2007年，渥太华县治安官办公室成立了一个新的未破案件调查组。一组调查人员将100%的时间投入到侦破旧案中。侦探戴夫·布莱克利（Dave Blakely）和阿维努斯·里珀（Avenus Ripper）将领导该小组。这两位侦探首先开始调查黛博拉·威尔逊案，该案同样未破。他们锁定了一个主要嫌疑人，但当他在被捕前死亡时，他们将注意力转向了布林克谋杀案。
When news broke that the case was being reopened, Gayle's mother, Dorothea, told reporters how she kept hoping the person responsible would be found. I would try my best, if they had a trial, to be there. Detectives Blakely and Ripper threw themselves into the case. Some of the paperwork from the previous investigations had deteriorated over time, so they taped them back together and handled each document with care as they examined them. They began conducting hundreds of interviews with individuals connected to the brinks, occasionally travelling interstate to speak with people. They scoured every statement, keeping an eye out for anything that seemed suspicious. At the very beginning of the investigation, detectives had made sure to speak with those closest to the victims, checking for alibis and motives. No one had seemed suspicious at the time.
当案件重新调查的消息传出时，盖尔的母亲多萝西娅（Dorothea）告诉记者，她一直希望找到凶手。“如果他们有审判，我会尽我所能去现场。”侦探布莱克利和里珀全身心投入到案件中。由于以前调查的一些纸质文件随时间而退化，他们用胶带将其重新粘好，并在检查时小心翼翼地处理每一份文件。他们开始对与布林克夫妇有关的人进行数百次采访，偶尔跨州与人交谈。他们仔细审查每一份声明，寻找任何可疑之处。在调查之初，侦探们确保与受害者身边的人交谈，核实不在场证明和动机。当时没有人显得可疑。
Two decades later, as detectives Blakely and Ripper examined the old case notes, they started to notice a pattern. Some of Gayle's family members mentioned that after the couple's murder, one individual who was close to Gayle had said some strange things. In one instance, the family had been gathered together just three days after the murders. In the middle of a conversation about the tragedy, one of Gayle's relatives told another how he could picture someone walking down the hallway of the couple's home. The person saw Gayle lying in bed and turning over on her left side, then told her, I'll be right back. He described the chilling scene as though he'd seen it himself, and then he also remarked, you know, sometimes I wonder if I could have done this. The person who made these comments was Ryan Winegarden, Gayle's older brother.
二十年后，当侦探布莱克利和里珀检查旧案笔记时，他们开始注意到一个模式。盖尔的一些家属提到，这对夫妇被谋杀后，一个与盖尔亲近的人说了一些奇怪的话。有一次，家属们在谋杀案发生仅仅三天后聚在一起。在讨论这场悲剧的过程中，盖尔的一个亲戚对另一个人说，他能想象出一个人走过这对夫妇家的走廊。这个人看到盖尔躺在床上并向左侧翻身，然后对她说：“我马上回来。”他描述这个令人不寒而栗的场景时，就好像他亲眼看到的一样，然后他还评论说：“你知道，有时我在想我是否能做到这一点。”说这些话的人是瑞安·温加顿，盖尔的大哥。
Investigators had no idea why Gayle's own brother would say such things. According to the case notes, Ryan Winegarden said that on the night of the murders, he and his then-girlfriend named Pam had been doing laundry. Ryan had been living in an apartment at the time and typically did his washing at a laundromat, but he and Pam didn't have enough change on that particular day. So they'd gone to a friend's house to use her washing machine and also helped out by babysitting her kids. Pam had confirmed this alibi, but as detectives Blakely and Repa went through their documents, they suddenly noticed the discrepancy. Pam's statement supported Ryan's version of events, but during the course of the investigation, she'd also agreed to sit for a polygraph test. When asked by the polygraph examiner if she had been with Ryan on the night of the murders, Pam had answered, no. The two detectives decided they should pay Ryan and Pam a visit.
调查人员不知道为什么盖尔的亲哥哥会说出这样的话。根据案件记录，瑞安·温加顿说，在谋杀案发生的当晚，他和当时的同居女友帕姆（Pam）一直在洗衣服。瑞安当时住在公寓里，通常在自助洗衣店洗衣服，但那一天他和帕姆没有足够的零钱。所以他们去了一个朋友家借用她的洗衣机，并帮忙照顾她的孩子。帕姆证实了这一不在场证明，但随着侦探布莱克利和里珀查阅文件，他们突然发现了矛盾之处。帕姆的陈述支持了瑞安的说法，但在调查过程中，她也同意接受测谎仪测试。当测谎仪检查员问她在谋杀案当晚是否和瑞安在一起时，帕姆回答“没有”。这两位侦探决定去拜访瑞安和帕姆。
Back in November 1987, the couple had only been dating for a few months. At the time, Pam was a single mother to a six-month-old son. Pam and Ryan married in 1989 and later went on to have three children together. By the time detectives Blakely and Repa went to speak with them, they'd been married for 23 years. The detectives pulled up at the trailer where the couple resided. They were met by Ryan, who explained that Pam wasn't home. The three of them chatted for a little while, but Ryan seemed to have difficulty recalling much detail about the time of his sister's murder. Detectives Blakely and Repa explained that they also wished to speak with Pam, so they arranged for her to attend the sheriff's department for an interview.
早在1987年11月，这对情侣才交往了几个月。当时，帕姆是一个六个月大男孩的单亲妈妈。帕姆和瑞安于1989年结婚，后来生了三个孩子。当侦探布莱克利和里珀去找他们谈话时，他们已经结婚23年了。侦探们把车停在两人居住的拖车前。瑞安出来迎接他们，解释说帕姆不在家。他们三人聊了一会儿，但瑞安似乎很难回忆起他妹妹被杀时的很多细节。侦探布莱克利和里珀解释说，他们也希望与帕姆谈谈，于是安排她去治安官办公室接受采访。
Ryan escorted her there. He also insisted that he be allowed to sit in on the interview. The detectives refused to permit this, explaining that they needed to speak to Pam alone. Once they were seated in an interrogation room, Pam repeated the same story she'd originally told investigators. She and Ryan had been together on the night of November 21, 1987, doing laundry at a friend's house. But the investigators didn't believe her. Feeling as though they were finally on track to cracking the case, detectives Blakely and Repa began digging into Ryan and Pam Weingarten's backgrounds. They discovered that in November 1987, Ryan's life had been somewhat difficult. He'd been making money by dealing drugs, but was struggling financially.
瑞安陪她去了。他还坚持要求旁听采访。侦探们拒绝了这一要求，解释说他们需要单独与帕姆谈谈。一旦他们坐在审讯室里，帕姆就重复了她最初对调查人员说的话。1987年11月21日晚，她和瑞安在一起，在一个朋友家里洗衣服。但调查人员不相信她。侦探布莱克利和里珀觉得他们终于走上了破案的正轨，于是开始挖掘瑞安和帕姆·温加顿的背景。他们发现，在1987年11月，瑞安的生活有些艰难。他靠贩毒赚钱，但经济拮据。
He'd also been juggling multiple relationships, having started dating Pam while he was still involved with a long-term ex-girlfriend named Crystal. Crystal and Ryan Weingarten had known each other for years and remained friends even after splitting up. For a few months, she and Pam were seeing Ryan at the same time, though Crystal's relationship was waning while Pam's was just beginning. Investigators realized that Crystal might be able to shed some light on Ryan's situation at the time of his sister's murder. They called her in for an interview. Crystal was happy to speak with the police, but didn't provide them with anything of much interest. She said she had remained good friends with Ryan over the years. Nothing new came up.
他还周旋于多段感情之间，在与长期前女友克里斯塔尔（Crystal）交往的同时，开始和帕姆约会。克里斯塔尔和瑞安·温加顿认识多年，即使分手后也一直是朋友。有几个月，她和帕姆同时与瑞安交往，尽管克里斯塔尔的感情在减弱，而帕姆的感情才刚开始。调查人员意识到克里斯塔尔或许能阐明瑞安在他妹妹被杀时的情况。他们把她叫来接受采访。克里斯塔尔很高兴与警方交谈，但没有提供什么有价值的信息。她说这些年她和瑞安一直是好朋友。没有出现什么新情况。
Detectives Blakely and Repa were disappointed. They'd hoped they were finally making some progress. Now it looked as though they were stalled yet again. The pair of them began wrapping up the interview and prepared to call it a day. As Detective Repa later told the television program a wedding and a murder, they thanked Crystal for her time and were starting to rise from their seats when Crystal blurted out. Well, there is this one other thing. The two detectives exchanged a glance, then sat back down.
侦探布莱克利和里珀感到失望。他们曾希望自己终于取得了一些进展。现在看起来他们似乎又陷入停顿了。两人开始结束采访并准备收工。正如侦探里珀后来告诉电视节目《婚礼与谋杀案》的那样，他们感谢克里斯塔尔抽空接受采访，正要起身时，克里斯塔尔突然脱口而出：“好吧，还有一件事。”两位侦探对视了一眼，然后又坐了下来。
What Crystal said next set the investigation on an entirely new trajectory. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions an average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our net zero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca. In the week after Gail and Rick Brink were murdered,
克里斯塔尔接下来所说的话使调查走向了全新的方向。投资于技术与创新。每桶排放量平均已减少22%。与政府合作创造和保护就业岗位。开发世界最大的碳捕集与储存设施之一。我们的净零计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请在pathwaysalliance.ca查看我们的行动计划。在盖尔和里克·布林克被谋杀后的一个星期里，
Ryan Weingarten paid a visit to his ex-girlfriend, Crystal. He invited Crystal to get in his car, suggesting that they go for a drive. He explained that he wanted to go by the house where his sister had been killed to take a look at it. This scared Crystal. She didn't want to see the place where two people had been brutally murdered just a few days earlier and refused to go. Ryan offered a compromise, saying they could drive somewhere else instead. They wound up heading to the northern side of Holland and pulled over at a park. Then Ryan spoke.
瑞安·温加顿拜访了他的前女友克里斯塔尔。他邀请克里斯塔尔上车，建议去兜风。他解释说想去他妹妹遇害的房子看一看。这吓坏了克里斯塔尔。她不想看到几天前两个人惨遭谋杀的地方，拒绝前往。瑞安妥协说，他们可以去别的地方。他们最后来到了荷兰镇北部，把车停在公园里。然后瑞安开口了。
He said he had something terrible to share. He hesitated to speak further. It took another five minutes before he finally proceeded. Ryan told Crystal that he'd had sex with his sister, Gail. It had started as sexual curiosity when he was 12 years old and Gail was 9. Initially there had just been some touching, but during their adolescence it progressed to intercourse. He was adamant that it had been consensual, though he became tearful when describing the last time he'd been intimate with Gail. She had been sitting on a bench behind the garage at their family home when Ryan walked up behind her.
他说他有一件可怕的事要分享。他犹豫着不敢多说。又过了五分钟，他才终于继续说下去。瑞安告诉克里斯塔尔，他曾和妹妹盖尔发生过性关系。这始于他12岁、盖尔9岁时的性好奇。起初只是一些抚摸，但在他们青春期时发展成了性交。他坚信这是双方自愿的，但在描述最后一次与盖尔亲密接触时，他流下了眼泪。她当时坐在他们家车库后面的一张长凳上，瑞安走到她身后。
He tried initiating sexual contact and Gail refused. Ryan wouldn't take no for an answer. In Crystal's words, he pretty much forced her to do it. Ryan had also shown Crystal a photograph of him and Gail that was taken while they were out on a boat with Gail's husband, Rick. Gail was wearing a bikini and Ryan remarked, look how hot she is. Crystal was taken aback by this comment. Ryan continued speaking. While they'd been on the boat, he had been so captivated by Gail's appearance that he openly stared at her in what he described as a lustful way.
他试图发起性接触，但盖尔拒绝了。瑞安不肯罢休。用克里斯塔尔的话来说，“他几乎是强迫她这么做的。”瑞安还向克里斯塔尔展示了一张他和盖尔的照片，那是他们和盖尔的丈夫里克一起在船上时拍的。盖尔穿着比基尼，瑞安评论说：“看她多辣。”克里斯塔尔对这句话感到吃惊。瑞安继续说。在船上时，他被盖尔的外表迷住了，以至于他以一种他形容为色迷迷的方式公开盯着她看。
At one point, he tore his eyes away from his sister only to realise that his ogling hadn't gone unnoticed. Rick was watching him. This was the breakthrough investigators had been looking for. Finally, they suspected they had a motive for the double homicide. Despite Ryan telling Crystal that his encounters with Gail had been consensual, detectives were certain they hadn't been. If Ryan had raped his sister during their childhood and adolescence, then perhaps he resented her marriage to another man. Moreover, he may have been fearful that as Gail grew increasingly comfortable with her new life and her husband, she would confide in Rick, telling him the truth about the abuse she'd endured.
有一次，他把视线从妹妹身上移开，才意识到他的色迷迷并没有被忽视。里克正在看着他。这是调查人员一直在寻找的突破口。最后，他们怀疑他们找到了双重谋杀的动机。尽管瑞安对克里斯塔尔说他和盖尔的接触是自愿的，但侦探们确信并非如此。如果瑞安在童年和青春期强奸了他的妹妹，那么他可能会怨恨她嫁给别人。此外，他可能担心随着盖尔越来越适应她的新生活和丈夫，她会向里克吐露实情，告诉他她所遭受虐待的真相。
The fact that Rick had noticed the way Ryan looked at Gail suggested he may have already had some idea. But Crystal's story wasn't enough. Detectives Blakely and Rapper knew that if they were ever going to solve this case, then they needed testimony from someone even closer to Ryan. His wife Pam Further appointments were made to interview Pam and Ryan. The two arrived at the sheriff's department together, though they'd driven in separate cars. While his wife came across as mild-mannered and somewhat meek, Ryan seemed abrasive and controlling.
里克注意到瑞安看盖尔的方式，这表明他可能已经有了一些想法。但克里斯塔尔的故事还不够。侦探布莱克利和里珀知道，如果他们想破获此案，他们需要来自比瑞安更亲近的人的证词。他的妻子帕姆。他们预约再次采访帕姆和瑞安。两人一起到达治安官办公室，尽管他们开着不同的车。当他的妻子显得温和且有些顺从时，瑞安显得粗鲁且具有控制欲。
Convincing him to wait outside while his wife spoke with detectives was a difficult task. Pam seemed reluctant to open up. The minutes dragged on, turning into hours. Finally, she made an admission. The alibi she'd provided for her husband for the night of the murders had been false. They had gone to a laundromat together on Saturday, November 21, leaving between 5 and 6pm, but they were home no later than 8. At that point, Ryan went out by himself for a few hours.
说服他在妻子与侦探交谈时在外面等待是一项艰巨的任务。帕姆似乎不愿敞开心扉。时间一分一秒过去，变成了几个小时。最后，她做出了承认。她为丈夫提供的谋杀当晚的不在场证明是假的。他们于11月21日星期六一起去了一家自助洗衣店，在下午5点到6点之间离开，但他们不晚于8点回到家。在那之后，瑞安一个人出去了几个小时。
Pam didn't ask where he was headed. He returned later on, and the two smoked cannabis, then had sex. Ryan soon left again, and Pam didn't see him until the following morning of Sunday, November 22. He'd insisted that she provide him with an alibi over the years. Before they'd gone to their interviews that day, he reminded her yet again of where they had supposedly been on the night in question. Though Pam conceded that the alibi had been false, she remained silent on other matters. She said nothing about an incestuous relationship her husband might have had with his sister, nor did she say that she suspected him of committing murder.
帕姆没有问他去哪里。他后来回来了，两人抽了大麻，然后发生了性关系。瑞安很快又出去了，帕姆直到第二天11月22日早上才见到他。多年来，他一直坚持让她为他提供不在场证明。在他们那天去接受采访之前，他再次提醒她他们那天晚上据称在哪里。虽然帕姆承认不在场证明是假的，但她在其他事情上保持沉默。她没有提到她的丈夫可能与他妹妹有乱伦关系，也没有说她怀疑他犯了谋杀罪。
Detectives had been questioning Pam for close to three hours. By this stage, Ryan, who thought the interview was only supposed to take 30 minutes, was enraged. He banged on the glass window of the interrogation room, demanding that Pam be let go. It was Ryan's turn to speak with the detectives next. Now that they knew his alibi was false, they were eager to interrogate him. As detailed in the television show A Wedding and a Murder, Detective Blakely was the one who raised the subject of Ryan's feelings towards his sister Gale. When he asked Ryan about the sibling's relationship,
侦探们审问帕姆将近三个小时。此时，以为采访只需要30分钟的瑞安勃然大怒。他敲打着审讯室的玻璃窗，要求放了帕姆。接下来轮到瑞安和侦探谈话了。既然他们知道他的不在场证明是假的，他们就急于审问他。正如电视节目《婚礼与谋杀案》中所详细描述的那样，侦探布莱克利提出了瑞安对妹妹盖尔的感情的话题。当他问瑞安关于兄妹关系时，
Ryan gazed back at him with a hostile expression on his face. What do you mean, he asked? Blakely stared back at Ryan without saying a word for several long moments. Then he replied, You know exactly what I mean, sexually. A long silence followed. Detective Ripper estimated that 40 seconds went by with no one speaking. Then, finally, Ryan said,
瑞安带着敌意的表情回望着他。“你什么意思？”他问。布莱克利一言不发地回望着瑞安好几分钟。然后他回答：“你知道我到底是什么意思，性方面的。”随之而来的是长时间的沉默。侦探里珀估计有40秒没有人说话。最后，瑞安说，
Well, it was just kids play. He claimed that as children, the two of them had merely explored each other's bodies, comparing the encounters to a game of doctors and nurses. Neither Detective Blakely nor Detective Ripper believed Ryan. They were certain he had assaulted his sister and was now attempting to downplay the abuse. The interview concluded and Ryan went home. Over the next few days, he started placing numerous phone calls to Detective Blakely. Most of the time, these calls went to voicemail so Ryan would leave a message.
“好吧，那只是小孩子过家家。”他声称，作为孩子，他们两人只是探索了彼此的身体，将这些遭遇比作医生和护士的游戏。侦探布莱克利和里珀都不相信瑞安。他们确信他袭击了他的妹妹，现在正试图淡化虐待行为。采访结束了，瑞安回家了。在接下来的几天里，他开始给布莱克利侦探打无数电话。大多数时候，这些电话转到了语音信箱，所以瑞安会留下一条消息。
He spoke of his gratitude that Blakely was working on his sister's case, while also expressing feelings of hatred towards him and his policing partner. On one occasion, he greeted the detective by stating, This is Ryan Wine Garden. I don't know why I'm calling you again. I guess because I hate you and appreciate you at the same time. Ryan described the detectives as sons of bitches, while conceding simultaneously that they were a necessary evil.
他谈到自己很感激布莱克利正在处理他姐姐的案子，同时也表达了对布莱克利及其警探搭档的憎恨。有一次，他向这位侦探打招呼时说道：“我是瑞恩·温加顿。我不知道我为什么又给你打电话。我想是因为我恨你，但同时又很感激你。”瑞恩把侦探们称为混蛋，但同时也承认他们是“必要的恶”。
Other messages were more direct. In one, he demanded, You go find my sister's killer. You're barking up the wrong tree here. I know nothing about it. He suggested that motorcycle gangs were responsible for the slayings. Another time, he warned, Digging up dirt from our family history, childhood indiscretions,
其他的信息则更为直接。在其中一条信息中，他要求道：“你们去找出我姐姐的杀人凶手吧。你们这是找错对象了。我对这件事一无所知。”他暗示摩托车帮派是这起谋杀案的罪魁祸首。另一次，他警告说：“挖掘我们家族历史中的污点、童年的轻率行为，
That's not going to shed any more light on it. Ryan accused both detectives of harassing his wife and called them assholes for what they'd put her through. As the calls and messages continued to stream in, Detectives Blakely and Repa realized that Ryan was unstable and unpredictable. They needed to act soon. Pam Wine Garden had already shown signs of opening up at her prior interview. The detectives knew that if they could convince her to speak again, She might be the one to blow the case wide open.
这并不会使案件有更多明朗的进展。”瑞恩指责两位侦探骚扰他的妻子，并因为他们让她经历的一切而骂他们是混蛋。随着电话和信息如潮水般不断涌来，布莱克利和雷帕侦探意识到瑞恩情绪不稳定且难以捉摸。他们必须尽快采取行动。帕姆·温加顿在之前的面谈中已经表现出愿意敞开心扉的迹象。侦探们知道，如果他们能说服她再次开口，她或许就能成为彻底打破僵局的关键人物。
But now their efforts to reach out to Pam were being blocked by Ryan. To gain a deeper understanding of the dynamic at play, Blakely and Repa consulted a psychologist who was familiar with domestic abuse and coercive control. Finally, in January 2013, they decided to approach Pam while she was at work. As Detective Repa later told the television program a wedding and a murder, They explained to Pam that they were a cold case unit who worked exclusively on old unsolved crimes. That meant that they wouldn't be going away. The only thing they wanted was the truth.
但现在，他们联系帕姆的努力却受到了瑞恩的阻挠。为了更深入地了解其中复杂的动态，布莱克利和雷帕咨询了一位熟悉家庭暴力和强制控制的心理学家。最终，在2013年1月，他们决定趁帕姆在上班时接近她。正如侦探雷帕后来在电视节目《一场婚礼与一场谋杀》中所说的那样，他们向帕姆解释说，他们是一个专门处理长期未破旧案的冷案调查组。这意味着他们不会轻易放弃。他们想要的唯一东西就是真相。
A human resources representative had escorted Pam to the meeting, But she asked that they not sit in on it so she could speak to the detectives in private. Pam was finally ready to speak. When Gail and Rick had died, Pam had only been dating Ryan for a few months. She was a new mother and Ryan was supportive even though he wasn't the baby's father. Pam reiterated how she and Ryan visited the laundromat in the late afternoon or early evening of November 21, 1987. Afterwards, they returned to her place when at about 8 o'clock, Ryan went out alone. He returned briefly before going out again.
一名人力资源代表曾陪同帕姆参加会面，但帕姆要求他们不要旁听，以便她能与侦探私下交谈。帕姆终于准备好开口了。盖尔和里克去世时，帕姆和瑞恩交往才几个月。她是一位年轻的母亲，而瑞恩虽然不是孩子的亲生父亲，却给予了她支持。帕姆重申了她和瑞恩如何在1987年11月21日傍晚或深夜去了自助洗衣店。之后，他们回到了她的住处，大约在8点钟，瑞恩独自一人出了门。他短暂地回来过一次，然后又出去了。
Pam maintained that she didn't see him again until 9 the next morning. There was a loud knocking at the door. When Pam answered it, Ryan was standing there crying and holding his head. What's wrong, Pam asked. Ryan replied that he just shot and killed his sister and her husband. Shocked and unable to believe what she was hearing, Pam asked Ryan to repeat what he just said. He did. Pam asked if he'd told the police. Ryan said no. Ryan claimed he'd gone over to the Brinks house to discuss some family matter and it had resulted in a heated argument. Rick had asked him to leave and Ryan initially did so. But then he walked back to the house complaining of car trouble. Rick went out to his own truck so he could get something to help and that's when Ryan shot him.
帕姆坚称直到第二天早上9点她才再次见到他。当时门外传出了急促的敲门声。帕姆去开门时，只见瑞恩站在那里哭泣，双手抱头。帕姆问：“怎么了？”瑞恩回答说，他刚刚开枪打死了他姐姐和姐夫。帕姆感到震惊，简直不敢相信自己听到的话，便让瑞恩重复他刚才说的话。他照做了。帕姆问他有没有报警。瑞恩说没有。瑞恩声称他去布林克斯家是为了讨论一些家庭事务，结果引发了一场激烈的争吵。里克要求他离开，瑞恩最初照做了。但随后他又抱怨汽车出了毛病，步行回到了那所房子。里克走到自己的卡车旁去拿能帮忙的东西，就在那时，瑞恩向他开了枪。
Then he went inside and killed Gail while she was lying in bed. He told Pam that he'd done it because the couple thought they were too good. Upset and confused by Ryan's statement, Pam asked him to leave. He did but he called her later that day and asked if he could come over. Pam reluctantly agreed. Ryan pulled up at Pam's and said he wanted to take her back to his apartment. She got in the car with her six month old son but Ryan didn't drive to his home. Instead he took them to the street where Gail and Rick lived. Ryan pulled over a short distance from their house then instructed Pam to get out.
然后他走进屋里，趁盖尔躺在床上时杀害了她。他告诉帕姆他这么做是因为这对夫妇自命不凡。帕姆对瑞恩的话感到心烦意乱、困惑不解，便要求他离开。他照做了，但当天晚些时候他又打来电话，问他能不能过来。帕姆不情愿地同意了。瑞恩开车来到帕姆家，说想带她回他的公寓。她带着六个月大的儿子上了车，但瑞恩并没有开车回他的住处。相反，他把他们带到了盖尔和里克居住的那条街上。瑞恩把车停在离他们家不远的一小段距离处，然后指示帕姆下车。
Pam walked with Ryan towards the Brink residence. Rick's truck was parked in the driveway. Ryan led Pam over to the vehicle and she looked inside. Rick's dead body was crumpled across the front seats. Then Ryan grabbed Pam's wrist and marched her over to the house. They walked inside and he led her up the hallway to the couple's bedroom. By this stage Pam was crying. She saw Gail lying in bed. Gail looked as though she could be asleep. Then Ryan lifted the blood-stained pillow that covered her head and asked,
帕姆和瑞恩一起向布里姆的住所走去。里克的卡车停在车道上。瑞恩把帕姆带到车前，她向里面看去。里克的尸体瘫软在前排座位上。接着，瑞恩抓住帕姆的手腕，拉着她朝房子走去。他们走进屋里，他顺着过道把她带到了这对夫妇的卧室。此时帕姆已经在哭了。她看到盖尔躺在床上。盖尔看起来就像睡着了一样。接着，瑞恩掀开盖在她头上带有血迹的枕头，问道：
Isn't she beautiful? Then he added, If you go to the police or tell anybody what I did here, this could happen to you. Pam ran from the house in fear. She was too terrified to call for help or make a sound but she couldn't stand to be in the Brink home a moment longer. Ryan took her back to his place and she stayed there that night. Pam woke early the following morning at around six. She got up to fix a bottle for her son and noticed that one of Ryan's friends,
“她不是很漂亮吗？”接着他又补充道：“如果你去找警察，或者把我在对这里做的事告诉任何人，这就会发生在你身上。”帕姆吓得从房子里跑了出去。她吓得不敢呼救，也发不出一点声音，但她一刻也不想在布里姆家里待下去了。瑞恩把她带回了他的住处，她那天晚上就留在了那里。第二天清晨六点左右，帕姆醒了得很早。她起身为儿子冲奶粉，发现瑞恩的一个朋友、
a man named Jimbo Meacham, was over. This wasn't unusual. Jimbo often stopped by before work for a coffee. Pam overheard Ryan tell his friend that his sister and her husband had just been killed. The rest of his family wouldn't learn about the slayings until later that day after Rick's employer alerted his parents to his uncharacteristic absence from work. When investigators later queried Jimbo about this encounter, he said he remembered it but couldn't recall if it had happened on Monday morning or Tuesday. After Jimbo left to go to work, Pam asked Ryan if he could take her home.
一个名叫吉姆博·米查姆的男人也在。这并不罕见。吉姆博经常在上班前顺便过来喝杯咖啡。帕姆无意中听到瑞恩告诉他的朋友，他的姐姐和姐夫刚刚被杀害。他的其他家人直到那天晚些时候才得知这起凶杀案，当时里克的雇主向他的父母通报了他反常的旷工情况。当调查人员后来就这次偶遇询问吉姆博时，他说他记得这件事，但记不清是发生在周一早上还是周二了。吉姆博上班离开后，帕姆问瑞恩能不能送她回家。
She needed to get ready for her own job. Ryan agreed but before they departed, he pulled something out to show her. It was a .22 revolver, the gun he'd used to shoot Gale and Rick. Ryan also showed Pam a bag filled with clothing, which he explained was what he'd been wearing when he committed the murders. He stashed the clothes and gun in the back of his car before getting in to drive Pam home. As they headed towards Pam's residence, Ryan again warned Pam not to breathe a word of what he'd told her to anyone else.
她得为自己的工作做准备了。瑞恩答应了，但在他们离开之前，他掏出一个东西给她看。那是一把.22口径左轮手枪，就是他用来射杀盖尔和里克的枪。瑞恩还向帕姆展示了一个装满衣服的袋子，他解释说这就是他犯下谋杀案时穿的衣服。他把衣服和枪藏在汽车后备箱里，然后上车送帕姆回家。在他们驶向帕姆住处的路上，瑞恩再次警告帕姆，绝不能把对她说过的话透露给任何人半句。
If she did, then what happened to Gale would happen to her. Ryan instructed Pam to tell the police that they'd been together on Saturday night at a friend's house doing laundry and babysitting. Terrified, Pam agreed. At one point, she'd asked Ryan why he'd murdered his own sister. He admitted that he'd had a sexual relationship with Gale and didn't want Rick to find out about it. Ryan also said he'd been jealous of the couple. The rest of Ryan's family soon learned of the murders.
如果她这么做了，那发生在盖尔身上的事就会降临到她头上。瑞恩指示帕姆告诉警察，周六晚上他们一直和朋友呆在一起洗衣服、照看孩子。吓坏了的帕姆答应了。有一次，她问瑞恩为什么要谋杀自己的亲姐姐。他承认自己和盖尔有过性关系，并且不想让里克发现。瑞恩还说他嫉妒这对夫妇。瑞恩的其他家人很快也知道了这起谋杀案。
As Pam went through the morning process alongside them, she felt as though she had swept everything she knew under the rug. She attended Gale and Rick's funeral with their grieving relatives, keeping Ryan's secret the entire time. In December 1987, investigators questioned Pam regarding her and Ryan's whereabouts on the day of the murders. She repeated the story Ryan had told her to tell and he was ruled out as a possible suspect. Occasionally, Ryan would remind Pam of the alibi they'd agreed on and his threat to harm her if she ever told anyone the truth.
当帕姆和他们一起经历早晨的哀悼流程时，她觉得自己把所知道的一切都掩盖了起来。她和悲痛欲亲属们一起参加了盖尔和里克的葬礼，自始至终保守着瑞恩的秘密。1987年12月，调查人员就她和瑞恩在谋杀案发生当天的行踪盘问了帕姆。她重复了瑞恩让她说的那套说辞，于是瑞恩被排除在潜在嫌疑人之外。偶尔，瑞恩会提醒帕姆他们商定好的不在场证明，以及如果她敢把真相告诉任何人就会伤害她的威胁。
Pam married Ryan in 1989 and he became a stepfather to Pam's young son. The couple went on to have three children together. Pam was the family breadwinner working to support the six of them while Ryan home-schooled their children. Pam wasn't happy with her children being educated at home but Ryan was a controlling husband and she had a little say in the matter. The more time that passed, the less Pam felt able to tell the truth. She did love Ryan despite what he'd done.
帕姆于1989年与瑞恩结婚，瑞恩成了帕姆年幼儿子的继父。此后，两人又育有三个孩子。帕姆是家里的顶梁柱，工作养活他们六口人，而瑞恩则在家教导他们的孩子。帕姆并不乐意让孩子们在家接受教育，但瑞恩是个控制欲极强的丈夫，在这件事上她没有什么发言权。时间过得越久，帕姆越觉得无法说出真相了。尽管瑞恩做了那种事，她确实还是爱他的。
She was also terrified that if she revealed what had happened after years and then decades of lying, she could lose her children or wind up in prison. So she stayed married to Ryan for 24 years. Finally though, the pressure became too much to bear. When the cold case unit started looking into the brink homicides Pam started to feel that she couldn't hold everything she knew inside anymore. It was like a heavy burden on her shoulders weighing them down. After her first interview with the cold case detectives in October 2012
她也感到无比恐惧：如果把多年的谎言乃至几十年后的真相揭露出来，她可能会失去自己的孩子，或者锒铛入狱。因此，她和瑞恩保持了24年的婚姻。然而最终，这种压力变得让人难以承受。当冷案调查组开始调查布里姆家的谋杀案时，帕姆开始觉得她再也无法将所知的一切都憋在心里了。这就像是一副沉重的担子压在她的双肩上，让她透不过气来。在2012年10月她首次接受冷案侦探的面谈之后，
when she revealed that the alibi Ryan had given was false, Ryan was angry with her. He called her after his own interview and yelled, I can't believe you threw me under the bus. Then he started ranting that the detectives must have bullied her. Pam didn't agree with this accusation. Her distress was obvious to detectives Blakely and Ripper. She cried constantly while describing how Ryan had taken her to see Gayle and Rick's bodies.
她透露瑞恩提供的不在场证明是假的，这让瑞恩对她感到非常愤怒。他在接受完自己的面谈后打电话给她并大喊道：“我真不敢相信你把我当成替罪羊抛弃了。”然后他开始咆哮，坚信是侦探们恐吓并逼迫了她。帕姆并不认同这种指控。侦探布莱克利和里珀一眼就能看出她的痛苦。她在描述瑞恩如何带她去看盖尔和里克的尸体时，一直在不停地哭泣。
What was also obvious was the fact that Ryan was desperately trying to contact her. Throughout the entire interview, Pam's phone had been pinging with calls and messages from her husband who was frantically attempting to reach her. It was decided that Ryan should be arrested as soon as possible. Detectives didn't want to give him any opportunity to flee or dispose of potential evidence. Officers were dispatched to Ryan's place of employment and took him into custody that same day. Ryan insisted he was innocent. Yet during an interview with police, he finally conceded one thing.
同样显而易见的事实是，瑞恩正拼命地试图联系她。在整个面谈过程中，帕姆的手机一直收到她丈夫打来的电话和发来的信息，她的丈夫正疯狂地试图与她取得联系。最终决定必须尽快逮捕瑞恩。侦探们不想给他任何逃跑或销毁潜在证据的机会。警方派警员前往瑞恩的工作地点，并在当天将他拘留。瑞恩坚称自己是无辜的。然而，在接受警方盘问时，他最终承认了一件事。
He said there had been an instance of quote, penetration between him and Gayle. He insisted it was entirely consensual. Investigators didn't believe this at all. Without Gayle alive to tell her side of the story, they could never know the full truth. But it seemed clear that she had been a victim of her older brother in more ways than one. The news that someone had been arrested for murdering Gayle and Rick Brink was what their families had long been hoping to hear. For the wine gardens, the relief felt upon hearing that the killer had been apprehended was marred by the fact that he was one of their own. Ryan and Gayle's mother refused to believe that her son could have killed her daughter.
他说，他和盖尔之间曾有过引用“插入”行为。他坚称这完全是双方自愿的。调查人员根本不相信这种说法。由于盖尔已经不在人世，无法讲述她这一侧的故事，他们永远无法得知全部的真相。但显而易见的是，她在多方面都成为了她亲哥哥的受害者。有人因谋杀盖尔和里克·布里姆而被捕的消息，正是他们家人长久以来一直期盼听到的。对于温加顿家族来说，得知凶手落网的那种如释重负感，却因为凶手是他们自己人而蒙上了阴影。瑞恩和盖尔的母亲拒绝相信她的儿子会杀害自己的女儿。
But other members of the family accepted the news. Gayle had been particularly close to her older sister Cheryl. When she was alive, the two were best friends. In their last conversation together, Gayle had complained about the fact that Cheryl lived so far away from her. Cheryl received a call from the police alerting her to Ryan's arrest. They also informed her that Ryan had sexually assaulted Gayle throughout their childhood. On the TV show A Wedding and a Murder, Cheryl described how she felt literally sick to her stomach upon learning this. The thought that Gayle had kept the abuse to herself and suffered in silence for all those years was devastating.
但家族的其他成员接受了这个消息。盖尔和她的姐姐谢丽尔关系格外亲密。在她生前，两人是最好的朋友。在她们最后一次通话中，盖尔还曾抱怨谢丽尔离她住得太远。谢丽尔接到警方打来的电话，被告知瑞恩被捕了。他们还告知她，瑞恩在他们整个童年期间对盖尔实施了性侵。在电视节目《一场婚礼与一场谋杀》中，谢丽尔描述了她在得知这一消息时感到胃里一阵翻江倒海。一想到盖尔将虐待之事深埋心底，在长达数年的时间里默默承受痛苦，她就感到心碎欲绝。
Cheryl believed that Gayle must not have told her because she'd known Cheryl would have confronted Ryan. Strange things that Ryan had said and done in the past slowly began to make sense. In one conversation, he mentioned how he'd gone through Gayle's personal papers after her death. He'd found some letters from men that he didn't want their parents to see, so he destroyed them. Shortly before Gayle and Rick's funeral, Ryan gave his own chilling rendition of the crime to Cheryl, wherein the killer walked down the hallway of the brink home before coming across Gayle in bed. It ended with the remark, You know, sometimes I wonder if I could have done this.
谢丽尔相信，盖尔一定是因为知道谢丽尔会去找瑞恩对质，所以才没有告诉她。瑞恩过去说过和做过的那些奇怪的事情，现在慢慢开始变得说得通了。在一次谈话中，他提到自己曾在盖尔死后翻看她的个人文件。他发现了一些他不希望他们父母看到的男人的信件，于是把它们销毁了。就在盖尔和里克葬礼前不久，瑞恩向谢丽尔冷酷地演绎了他自己版本的犯罪过程：凶手走过布里姆家的过廊，然后碰到了躺在床上的盖尔。故事以这样一句话结尾：“你知道的，有时候我在想，我是不是也能干出这种事。”
Ryan had said something very similar to his aunt, Nava. At Gayle's funeral, he asked her, Do you think I could have killed them? Nava had received phone calls from both Ryan and Gayle the day before the murders. Gayle had complained that Ryan owed her money. Ryan was angry because Gayle was refusing to let their parents park their camper van in her driveway. They'd recently sold their home and were temporarily living in the camper. They'd initially parked it at Ryan's apartment building, but were soon instructed to move it as they were violating local ordinances.
瑞恩对他的姑姑娜瓦也说过类似的话。在盖尔的葬礼上，他问她：“你觉得我会不会杀了他们？”在谋杀案发生的头一天，娜瓦曾分别接到过瑞恩和盖尔的电话。盖尔曾抱怨瑞恩欠她钱。瑞恩则很生气，因为盖尔拒绝让他们的父母把房车停在她的车道上。他们最近刚卖了房子，暂时住在房车里。他们最初把房车停在瑞恩的公寓楼旁，但很快就被勒令移走，因为这违反了当地的条例。
Ryan wanted them to go to Gayle's house, but she didn't like the idea. Ryan told his aunt that Gayle thought she was too good for their family. A little while later, after Gayle's death, Ryan told Nava that Gayle and Rick would probably still be alive if they'd let her parents stay on the property. On another occasion, he told his other sister, Lynn, that he wished he could apologize to Gayle because he felt as though he'd raped her. He said something almost identical to one of his nieces. He'd even discussed his sexual feelings for Gayle with his stepson. Ryan had described their relationship as touchy-feely, but said it was normal adolescent exploration. Ryan told his stepson that sometimes Gayle would say no, so he would force her.
瑞恩希望他们去盖尔家，但她并不喜欢这个主意。瑞恩对姑姑说，盖尔自以为了不起，看不起他们全家。过了一会儿，在盖尔死后，瑞恩对娜瓦说，如果盖尔和里克当初让他们的父母留在那里，他们现在可能还活着。在另一个场合，他告诉他的另一个姐姐琳娜，他希望能向盖尔道歉，因为他觉得自己强奸了她。他对其中一个侄女也说过几乎一模一样的话。他甚至还和继子讨论过他对盖尔的性欲望。瑞恩曾形容他们的关系是“动手动脚的”，但坚称这只是青春期的正常探索。瑞恩告诉继子，有时盖尔会说不，所以他就强迫了她。
About 13 years after the murders, Cheryl had been chatting with Ryan on the phone. He mentioned how there had been a rodent in his yard, so, quote, I pulled out my 22 and shot it. Cheryl hadn't been aware that her brother owned a 22-gauge firearm, so she queried the statement. Ryan quickly corrected himself and said he'd used a different kind of gun, not a 22. In 2006, Cheryl and Ryan had a falling out. Their father had passed away and the fight related to veterans' benefits for their mother, Dorothea, who was now an elderly woman. They barely spoke in the years that followed. Then, all of a sudden, in October 2012, Ryan called Cheryl.
谋杀案发生大约13年后，谢丽尔曾在电话里和瑞恩闲聊。他提到院子里有一只啮齿动物，于是他引用说：“我掏出我的22口径枪把它给崩了。”谢丽尔并不知道她哥哥拥有一把.22口径的枪支，于是她对这种说法提出了质疑。瑞恩赶紧纠正自己，说他用的是另一种枪，不是.22口径的。2006年，谢丽尔和瑞恩闹翻了。他们的父亲去世了，而这场争执与他们当时已是老人的母亲多萝西娅的退伍军人津贴有关。在随后的几年里，他们几乎没有说过话。然后，就在2012年10月，瑞恩突然给谢丽尔打了个电话。
He wanted to tell her that he'd forgiven her. What Cheryl didn't know was that Ryan and his wife Pam had just been interviewed by the cold case unit at the Ottawa County Sheriff's Department. Investigators finally had him in their sights. Following Ryan's arrest, detectives searched his home and found a 22 calibre rifle. But they never found the 22 revolver that had been used to kill Gale and Rick Brink. Pam told them she'd seen her husband place the same style of revolver in his car the day after the couple were murdered. Investigators concluded that Ryan had disposed of it somewhere, along with the clothing he'd been wearing that night. Investigators also compared Ryan's fingerprints to the ones recovered from a telephone and a toilet in the Brink home.
他想告诉她，他已经原谅她了。谢丽尔并不知道的是，瑞恩和他的妻子帕姆刚刚在渥太华县警长办公室接受了冷案调查组的面谈。调查人员终于将他锁定在视线之内。瑞恩被捕后，侦探搜查了他的住所，并找到了一支.22口径的步枪。但他们始终没有找到那把用来杀害盖尔和里克·布里姆的.22口径左轮手枪。帕姆告诉他们，这对夫妇被谋杀的第二天，她曾看到丈夫把同款的左轮手枪放进车里。调查人员断定，瑞恩一定把枪连同他当晚穿的衣服一起扔在某个地方了。调查人员还将瑞恩的指纹与从布里姆家的一部电话和一个马桶上提取到的指纹进行了比对。
Neither were a match. But, despite the lack of physical evidence tying Ryan to the crime, they were certain they finally had their killer. Ryan Weingarten was charged with two counts of first degree murder. His trial began in March 2014 at the Ottawa County Circuit Court in Grand Haven, Michigan. The prosecution was arguing that Ryan had murdered his sister and her husband because he was scared Gale would reveal his incestuous abuse of her. The killings were also motivated by jealousy. He resented Gale and Rick's success. The prosecution had no physical evidence, but they did have 60 witnesses who were willing to testify. Chief among them was Ryan's wife, Pam.
两者并不相符。但是，尽管缺乏将瑞恩与该罪行直接联系起来的物证，他们仍然确信自己终于抓住了真凶。瑞恩·温加顿被指控两项一级谋杀罪。他的审判于2014年3月在密歇根州大黑文的渥太华县巡回法院开始。检方的论点是，瑞恩谋杀姐姐和姐夫是因为他害怕盖尔会揭发他对她实施的乱伦虐待。这起谋杀案也是出于嫉妒的动机。他嫉妒盖尔和里克的成功。检方虽然没有物证，但他们有60位愿意出庭作证的证人。其中最主要的证人就是瑞恩的妻子帕姆。
She looked scared as she took the stand, but spoke clearly and firmly about the things Ryan had said and done. Pam denied ever feeling pressured to turn state's witness against her husband. Instead, she said any pressure she experienced was due entirely to her own conscience. It was difficult for her to testify, especially when Ryan began shouting abuse at her from his seat at the defendants table. At one point, he called her a black-hearted evil woman and added, I can't believe you're saying all these lies about me, Pam. The judge had him removed from the courtroom. As well as detailing how Ryan had taken her to look at Gale and Rick's bodies, Pam described what life had been like with him.
她走上证人席时显得很害怕，但语气清晰坚定，讲述了瑞恩说过的话和做过的事。帕姆否认自己曾感到任何压力去充当指证丈夫的控方证人。相反，她表示她感受到的任何压力完全来自于她自己的良心。对她来说作证非常困难，特别是当瑞恩在被告席座位上开始对她大喊大叫、进行辱骂时。有一度，她被骂作“黑心恶毒的女人”，瑞恩还补充道：“帕姆，我真不敢相信你在说这些关于我的谎言。”法官下令将他逐出法庭。除了详细讲述瑞恩如何带她去看盖尔和里克的尸体外，帕姆还描述了和他生活在一起的日子是什么样的。
Ryan had been controlling and abusive. He hadn't allowed her to have friends of her own. Pam's father had also been emotionally abusive, and she thought that must be why Ryan was able to so successfully manipulate her. After his arrest, he started sending Pam a barrage of letters. Sometimes, he begged her to go back on her statement. Other times, he threatened her with God's wrath for going against him. In total, he sent 29 of these letters while he was on remand. A fellow inmate claimed that while Ryan was in custody awaiting trial, he'd boasted about committing the double homicide. According to this individual, Ryan also ranted about one of his other sisters, Cheryl.
瑞恩一直是个控制欲强且有虐待倾向的人。他不允许她有自己的朋友。帕姆的父亲也有情感虐待倾向，她认为这一定就是瑞恩能够如此成功地操控她的原因。他被捕后，开始给帕姆发狂轰滥炸般的信件。有时，他哀求她推翻自己的供词。有时，他又用上帝的愤怒来威胁她，责怪她与他作对。在候审期间，他总共寄出了29封这样的信件。一名同监狱的犯人声称，瑞恩在被拘留等待审判期间，曾吹嘘自己犯下了这起双重谋杀案。据这名个人所述，瑞恩还大骂了他的另一个姐姐谢丽尔。
He was furious at her because over the past 20 years, she'd constantly campaigned for law enforcement to solve Gale and Rick's murder. Ryan supposedly said to the other inmate, If I'd known she was going to cause me trouble like this, I would have killed that bitch a long time ago. Then, he mimed choking a person with his hands. The inmate testified at Ryan's trial in exchange for three years being taken off his own sentence. Ryan's defense team argued that the prisoner had a history of turning snitch when it benefited him. Ryan was pleading not guilty. In an attempt to argue for his innocence, the defense pointed at other possible suspects.
他极其愤怒，因为在过去的20年里，谢丽尔一直在不断呼吁执法部门侦破盖尔和里克的谋杀案。据说瑞恩对这名狱友说：“如果我知道她会给我惹来这样的麻烦，我早就把那个贱人给做掉了。”接着，他还用双手做出了掐一个人的动作。这名狱友在瑞恩的审判中作证，条件是为他自己的刑期减刑三年。瑞恩的辩护团队辩称，这名犯人有在对己有利时充当告密者的历史。瑞恩作了无罪抗辩。为了证明自己无罪，辩护方将矛头指向了其他潜在嫌疑人。
They suggested Gale and Rick had been murdered by a biker gang who mistook Rick for shotgun Sid, the drug dealing former owner of their property. They also theorized that Gale had been targeted by a colleague after she started investigating possible financial irregularities at work. They claimed there had been a file from Gale's work at the crime scene, but it was removed before it could be looked into. An official from the company where Gale was employed said he had gone to the house after learning of Gale's murder, but denied taking or asking police for any documents. The prosecution dismissed the suggestion that Gale was executed by a workmate as little green men from Mars stuff. Ryan Weingarten testified in his own defense. His testimony was rambling and often irrelevant as he went off on strange tangents. Several times, the judge had to remind Ryan and his attorney to stay on track.
他们暗示盖尔和里克是被一个飞车帮谋杀的，对方把里克误认成了他们房产的前任毒贩房东“霰弹枪西德”。他们还推测，盖尔在开始调查工作中的可能财务违规行为后，成为了某位同事的目标。他们声称案发现场有一份来自盖尔工作单位的文件，但在被调查之前就被拿走了。盖尔受雇公司的官员表示，在得知盖尔被谋杀后他曾去过那所房子，但否认拿走或要求警察提供任何文件。检方对盖尔被同事处决的说法不屑一顾，斥其为“火星来的小绿人”般的无稽之谈。瑞恩·温加顿为自己进行了无罪辩护。他的证词东拉西扯、毫无逻辑，经常扯到一些奇怪的题外话上。法官数次不得不提醒瑞恩和他的律师切入正题。
Under cross-examination, Ryan was grilled about his relationship with Gale. Despite earlier admitting to police that he'd once had sex with his sister, Ryan now claimed he'd only said that under duress. He was adamant that there had only been three incidents with Gale that could be perceived as sexual. These incidents involved comparing their bodies after bathing and touching and groping while clothed. As prosecutors continued to pursue this line of questioning, Ryan became increasingly upset, stating, You guys are making it into a mockery and you need a motive and there is no motive. He began to cry and questioned why his sister Cheryl and wife Pam had both testified against him. He accused investigators of convincing Pam to lie and compared footage of her police interviews to a wolf pack chewing on an innocent lamb.
在交叉盘问中，瑞恩就他与盖尔的关系接受了严厉盘问。尽管此前曾向警方承认他曾与姐姐发生过性关系，但瑞恩现在声称他当时只是在胁迫下才那样说的。他坚认他和盖尔之间只有三次可以被视为与性有关的事件。这些事件包括洗澡后比较体形，以及在穿着衣服的情况下进行触摸和抚摸。随着公诉人继续穷追猛打这一系列问题，瑞恩变得越来越激动，他宣称：“你们这是在把这事当成儿戏，你们需要一个动机，但根本没有什么动机。”他开始哭泣，并质问为什么他的姐姐谢丽尔和妻子帕姆都要出庭指证他。他指责调查人员说服帕姆撒谎，并把她接受警方采访的录像比作“狼群在撕咬一只无辜的小羔羊”。
And then he suddenly said out of nowhere, Do I feel like I deserve to sue the county? Oh, absolutely. Ryan also denied being jealous of Gale and Rick's success. He loved his sister. She helped him out by co-signing a car loan for him and making one of his payments. He also said he had a good relationship with his brother-in-law. Ryan liked Rick's dry sense of humour and found him to be a super nice person. Ryan maintained that on the night of the murders, he and Pam had done laundry and babysat for a friend.
然后他突然没头没脑地说了一句：“我觉得我配起诉这个县吗？哦，绝对配。”瑞恩还否认自己嫉妒盖尔和里克的成功。他很爱他的姐姐。她曾为他的汽车贷款共同署名并替他代还了一笔款项，以此来帮他。他还说自己和姐夫的关系很好。瑞恩很喜欢里克冷面笑匠式的幽默感，觉得他是个超级好的人。瑞恩坚称在谋杀案当晚，他和帕姆一直在洗衣服并帮朋友带孩子。
He denied ever going out by himself. In fact, he said that Pam had gone out for drinks with a friend and returned home at about 2am. Ryan said that on the afternoon of Sunday, November 22, he was running low on petrol and cigarettes, so he stopped at a service station. He used the opportunity to try to call Gale from a pay phone. He had been planning to discuss the issue of their parents' camper van with her. Ryan was angry that Gale wouldn't let them park it at her property, but denied wanting to kill her over the matter. Ryan dialed Gale's number. No one answered the phone.
他否认自己曾独自外出。事实上，他说帕姆是和一个朋友出去喝酒，直到凌晨2点才回家。瑞恩说，在11月22日星期日的下午，他的汽油和香烟都快用完了，于是他在一个加油站停了下来。他借此机会试图从公用电话给盖尔打个电话。他本打算和她讨论父母房车的问题。瑞恩很生气盖尔不让他们把房车停在她家房产上，但否认想因此杀害她。瑞恩拨通了盖尔的电话。没有人接听电话。
He decided to go over to Pam's house instead. He claimed that he first learned of Gale and Rick's murders at 5pm on Monday, November 23 after he went over to his brother's house. Later that evening, Ryan headed over to Pam's house. She was watching the news and a story came on about the double murder. That was my sister and Rick, Ryan told her. Then he lay down on Pam's bed while sobbing. They killed my sister. On March 28, 2014, the jury delivered their verdict.
于是他决定改去帕姆家。他声称自己是在11月23日星期一晚上5点去哥哥家时，才第一次得知盖尔和里克被谋杀的。那天晚些时候，瑞恩前往帕姆家。她当时正在看新闻，正好播报了一则关于这起双重谋杀案的报道。“那是我的姐姐和里克，”瑞恩对她说。然后他躺在帕姆的床上痛哭起来。“他们杀了我姐姐。”2014年3月28日，陪审团作出了裁决。
They found Ryan Weingarten, now 51 years old, guilty of murdering Gale and Rick Brink. Ryan kept his head down as the verdict was read aloud. As he was escorted from the courtroom, he said, I didn't do this. Most members of the victim's family's welcomed the verdict. Outside court, Gale's sister Cheryl told reporters, We're done. We finally got him. He created this situation and now he has to pay for it.
他们裁定现年51岁的瑞恩·温加顿谋杀盖尔和里克·布里姆的罪名成立。宣读判决书时，瑞恩一直低着头。当他被押出法庭时，他说道：“我没有干这事。”受害者家属的大多数成员对这一判决表示欢迎。法院门外，盖尔的姐姐谢丽尔对记者说：“我们解脱了。我们终于抓到他了。这一切都是他造成的，现在他必须为此付出代价。”
Cheryl explained that although she still loved her brother, she hated who he had become and what he did. The pain of losing her sister had tormented her for almost 30 years. Rick's brother, Bud Brink, told news outlet M Live, We are extremely pleased to have the justice my brother deserves. At least this gives us some closure as to how it happened and why it happened. Although he said he wished Pam had come forward with the truth decades earlier, he appreciated her strength in finally doing so, adding, It took a lot for her to come forward.
谢丽尔解释说，尽管她依然爱她的哥哥，但她恨他现在的样子以及他所做的事。失去姐姐的痛苦折磨了她将近30年。里克的弟弟巴德·布里姆对新闻媒体M Live表示：“我们极其高兴能为我哥哥讨回他应得的正义。这至少让我们对事情是如何发生的以及为什么发生有了一个了结。”尽管他说他希望帕姆能早几十年站出来说出真相，但他对她最终站出来的坚强表示赞赏，并补充道：“她能站出来付出了巨大的勇气。”
Ryan's sentencing took place almost a month later. When he was given the opportunity to speak, he ranted and raved for an hour. At times, he stared tearfully up at the ceiling and addressed God directly, saying, Lord, why are you doing this to me? I'm a good man. Why? Why is this happening? When it was time for his sentence to be delivered, Ryan constantly interrupted the judge. Finally, the judge lost his patience and asked, Do I need to bind you and gag you, sir? We'll have the deputies go and duct tape you if that's what's necessary, but you're going to listen. He described the murders as a brutal execution and said Ryan was a brutal cold-blooded murderer
瑞恩的宣判在一个月后进行。当他获得发言机会时，他大声咆哮了整整一个小时。有时，他含泪凝视着天花板，直接对上帝喊话：“主啊，你为什么要对我做这种事？我是个好人。为什么？为什么会发生这种事？”轮到宣判时，瑞恩不断打断法官的话。最终，法官失去了耐心，问道：“先生，我需要把你捆起来再塞住嘴吗？如果真有必要，我们会让警员用强力胶带把你粘起来，但你必须给我听着。”他将谋杀案描述为一场残忍的处刑，并称瑞恩是一个冷血残酷的杀人犯，
before sentencing him to two life sentences with no possibility of parole. Most were pleased with this conclusion, with the exception of Gail and Ryan's mother, Dorothea. She didn't believe her son was guilty. She was overheard telling one investigator, I don't care what you say, you're wrong. Ryan Weingarten subsequently appealed his conviction at three different courts, including Michigan's Supreme Court. He lost all three appeals and remains incarcerated. Pam has divorced him. In December 2016, a former Ottawa County Sheriff declared the murder of Deborah Wilson solved.
随后判处他两项终身监禁且不得假释。除了盖尔和瑞恩的母亲多萝西娅之外，大多数人对这个结果都感到满意。她不相信自己的儿子有罪。有人听到她对一名调查人员说：“我不管你们怎么说，你们都错了。”此后，瑞恩·温加顿向包括密歇根州最高法院在内的三个不同法院对自己的定罪提起了上诉。他的三次上诉全部驳回，目前仍在服刑中。帕姆已经与他离婚。2016年12月，渥太华县前警长宣布黛博拉·威尔逊谋杀案告破。
Deborah had been murdered in December 1987 and investigators had initially wondered whether her killing could be connected to the Brink case. Prior to reopening the Brink investigation, cold case detectives had been looking at Deborah's case. They honed in on an acquaintance of Deborah's who was connected to the murder via some suspicious photographs. Unfortunately, he died before he could be arrested and charged, but detectives remained certain he was responsible. Deborah's family received a detailed briefing about the suspect and the case is now closed. The 1977 murder of Deborah Polinski, which was also looked at during the original Brink investigation, remains open. Detectives from the cold case unit at the Ottawa County Sheriff's Department continue to investigate the case.
黛博拉于1987年12月被谋杀，调查人员最初曾怀疑她的遇害是否与布里姆案有关。在重新启动布里姆案调查之前，冷案侦探们一直在调查黛博拉的案子。他们将目标锁定在黛博拉的一个熟人身上，此人通过一些可疑的照片与谋杀案联系在了一起。不幸的是，他在被捕和起诉前就去世了，但侦探们确信他难辞其咎。黛博拉的家人收到了关于该嫌疑人的详细案情通报，目前该案已告结。1987年黛博拉·波林斯基谋杀案（在最初调查布里姆案时也曾被审视过）目前依然悬而未决。渥太华县警长办公室冷案调查组的侦探们仍在继续调查此案。
Those who knew Gail and Rick Brink have spoken of their sorrow at losing two wonderful people. In the television program A Wedding and a Murder, a friend of Rick's described the double homicide as a loss to their community and the future. He was saddened that they never got the chance to be parents, saying, I can't imagine anything but Rick being the best dad in the world, and I can't imagine Gail being anyone but the most fun mum in the world. Gail's sister Cheryl says she thinks about Gail just about every day, quote, She'll flicker through my mind. It's not always sad because she was actually a very funny person and we had a great time together. But you don't forget. That's how you keep their memory alive. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那些认识盖尔和里克·布里姆的人纷纷表达了失去两个优秀之人的悲痛。在电视节目《一场婚礼与一场谋杀》中，里克的一位朋友将这起双重谋杀案形容为他们社区和未来的损失。他感到难过的是，他们两人从未有机会成为父母，并说道：“我无法想象里克会不是世界上最好的爸爸，我也无法想象盖尔会不是世界上最有趣的妈妈。”盖尔的姐姐谢丽尔说她几乎每天都会想起盖尔，她引述道：“她会在我的脑海中一闪而过。这并不总是悲伤的，因为她其实是一个非常有趣的人，我们曾度过了一段美好的时光。但你不会忘记。这就是你如何让他们的记忆永远活下去的方式。”本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。